you
we're here to present the outstanding
foreign language film award but actually
there is no such thing as a foreign film
is there film speak a universal language
no matter the country of their origin
the movies nominated tonight are notable
for their intelligence and their Grace
and were made by craftsmen who care very
deeply about their work and America is
affectionate of them all but to us
foreign audiences or essential and
they're important for the American film
finds a warm reception in more than a
hundred countries around the world and
for that we are deeply grateful we are
proud to present to you the nominations
for the outstanding foreign language
film of the year they are from Poland
the maids of Wilco Janusz Zapdos ski
director of film Polsky from spain mama
turns 100 Carlos Saura director in
France a simple story al asad producer
and from the German Federal Republic the
tin drum Volker chuan DAF director
familiy to forget venice franco blues at
the director the Federal Republic of
Germany for the tin drum
the hero of the tin drum you know is
named Oscar and for all the time we were
making the film we wanted what kind of
omen this could be so it's what it meant
it's a little boy actor he has in common
with this one of being small but only in
size you know it's the first award ever
given to a film of my country there's
been lots of reasons for that we know
but I take it as a tribute also for my
fellow directors over there and for all
those whose tradition we want to pick up
and follow and who worked and lived here
I mean Fritz Lang Billy Wilder Lubitsch
more now pops you know them all you
welcome them thank you